the Israelis are not simply going after
Hamas what the Israelis are doing is
they are purposely killing huge numbers
of civilians and the evidence for this
is overwhelming and the evidence comes
from inside Israel itself if you look at
the statements that Israeli leaders are
making and if you look at the
assessments of the bombing campaign that
are coming from inside Israel and are
well done assessments it's quite clear
that this is a classic punishment
campaign where the aim is to kill large
numbers of civilians and I believe and
there is a good amount of evidence to
support this that what the Israelis are
interested in doing in the end is
ethnically cleansing Gaza uh I believe
the Israelis would like to ethnically
cleanse Gaza and they would like to
ethnically cleanse the West Bank they'd
like to get rid of the
Palestinians uh from those two areas